be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
what's going on comic nation this is Rob
and welcome to week 2 of convergence now
I know I'm a little bit late here but I
actually forgot to get this video
produced and uploaded last week to be
honest with you guys so we're gonna go
ahead and produce this video today and
then tomorrow we'll cover convergence
week 3 now for those of you guys who are
new here
these are selections from convergence
the stories that I preferred and in
truth what we'll do is that once
convergence is completely finished I'll
let you guys decide which stories you'd
like to see covered in more depth here
on my youtube channel and then we'll go
from there
now week 2 of convergence largely takes
place and pre 0 our metropolis now pre 0
hour was DC's way to effectively fix
some continuity issues that had kind of
lingered along the lines after crisis on
Infinite Earths and so what had happened
in this story is that Hal Jordan had
basically become parallax and as a
result he had tried to I guess destroy
and recreate the DC Universe and this
was effectively again a way to recreate
year I guess to fix continuity issues
and so starting off with convergence
week 2 given the premise of zero hour
what better way to begin this video than
by covering the Green Lantern parallax
story with Green Lantern parallax issue
number one
now this comic was a comic I absolutely
loved and the reason why is because
rather than having Hal Jordan run around
it's parallax smashing the city to
pieces instead we get to see this really
cool meeting between Hal Jordan and Kyle
Rayner with Hal Jordan believing that he
had destroyed the Green Lantern Corps
while he was parallax now again keep in
mind here that when the dome is up over
any particular city everybody's lost
their powers and so both Kyle Rayner and
Hal Jordan do not have access to the
power stored within their Lantern rings
now the story itself is written in a way
that fills in the gaps telling us that
Hal Jordan was actually prepared to kill
Superman
before the domes had gone up and so once
the domes had gone up he had simply lost
his powers and he had basically come
back to his senses he had realized what
it was that he has done and he had
basically staved off his attack on
Superman and so again as with all
convergence titles this issue ends with
the dome coming down and the restoration
of both Kyle Rayner and Hal Jordans
power rings and so what this basically
does is it leaves us with a cliffhanger
the question if how Jordan is or I guess
he was parallax before the dome went up
will he come back as parallax will he be
parallax and if he is are we going to
see him and Kyle Rayner fight one
another and this I think is gonna be one
of the coolest premises of this entire
event so our second offering for
convergence week two is Aquaman number
one now again these stories take place
in the DC pries ero our timeline and it
largely takes place or I guess the story
largely takes a more philosophical look
at Aquaman now what's interesting here
is that in this story he's quite
literally a fish out of water and the
story largely focuses on how Aquaman
deals with being separated from the
ocean but in truth the story really
seems to like anything that makes it
stand out as a must-read in my book
Aquaman spends a majority of his time
basically just kind of pouting and
wishing that he were with Meera and he
even goes as far as to break into an
aquarium and claim it for his own before
the police arrive and try to subdue him
but again like all the convergence
titles so far what ends up happening is
that Tilos makes his grand announcement
telling the occupants of these various
stones but if they want the realities to
survive they're going to have to fight
other realities and so what is up
happening is that once the the donors
come down of course
Aquaman regains his powers but he
remains a fish out of water he remains
as a character who is isolated away from
his home and so what's interesting here
is that this story is basically I guess
the story of Aquaman is not going to see
him returning back to the ocean so the
question is what kind of a character is
he gonna be how is this character going
to progress but regardless if you're an
Aquaman fan if you are a character or I
guess a person who loved the character
of Aquaman this is probably a must read
for you so the next story on our list
and it's actually a story that I really
really enjoyed more than I thought I
would it's actually Green Arrow number
one now what's really cool about Green
Arrow number one is again this takes a
look at the zero hour or the pre zero
hour
I guess meet between Green Lantern's are
between Oliver Queen and Connor Hawke
now what was really interesting here
what I really enjoyed about this story
is that originally in zero hour when
Connor Hawke and Oliver Queen at first
met Oliver Queen actually hated the idea
didn't like the idea at all that he had
a
it was really kind of a shut eye shot in
the gut for him and so what had happened
is he actually he basically left kind of
got involved with this government group
and as a result when a bomb was sent to
Metropolis he ended up sacrificing his
life to keep metropolis from being
destroyed but nonetheless he learned I
guess the knowledge of his son set him
on that path they set him on the path of
self-destruction and in fact connor
hawke ended up undertaking the role of
green arrow for quite some time now
again what I think what we may be seeing
here or at least what make aynd of may
very well take place here is that we
could very well see a circumstance
whereby Connor Hawke ends up undertaking
the mantle of Oliver Queen or I guess of
Green Arrow at some point during this
two-part series and the reason I say
that is because with Part one and this
is basically a revamping of the meeting
between Oliver Queen and Connor Hawke
because this meeting plays out
differently than what we had seen in the
original zero hour event it stands to
reason that things may unfold
differently now again the question here
is are we going to see green arrow be
killed off or is of course he going to
survive and Connor Hawke is basically
just going to be a sidekick the way he
was in the comics before before Oliver
Queen had been killed but nonetheless
those of you guys who are big Green
Arrow fans or who are big fans of the
whole continuity or the relationship
between Green Arrow and Connor Hawke
this is definitely a story I would
suggest picking up if you haven't
already
now the next story on our list is
Suicide Squad number one now in truth
Suicide Squad number one was a story
that I was looking to more than almost
any of the other stories with the
exception of Superboy and so I was kind
of disappointed when I picked up this
story and found that part one of this
two-part series doesn't really have
anything happening here the story
largely focuses on Amanda Waller and how
she deals with the knowledge that the
domes are down and that they'll
eventually come face to face with the
Kingdom Come universe now she gives us a
brief explanation of the Kingdom Come
versions of Green Lantern and the fact
that he's Alan Scott the fact that he
was a recluse during the Kingdom Come
event that he basically just kind of had
this platform out on out in space where
he was constantly looking for Universal
threats to just never really seem to
come and that the I guess the universe
itself houses older versions of the
super
heroes that amanda waller and her
universe have and so again I'm added
this is largely build up this is
basically just kind of setting the stage
for what we'll see in part two but the
question is is this going to lead up or
is it going to I guess become the title
that we're really expecting is it going
to satisfy people who are Suicide Squad
fans and want to see a really good group
of Suicide Squad members going against a
powerhouse of Kingdom Come teams again
at this point we don't really know now
my personal favorite selection from
convergence week two is Superboy number
one now Superboy number one is probably
the best story to come out of
convergence so far the reason why is
simple convergence is a sort of last
hurrah to so many of the fan favorites
that were pre new 52 before the full
continuity reboot of all the characters
one of the most loved characters pre new
52 with Superboy and issue number one of
this part two series gives the fans
exactly what they want the leather
jackets Superboy this largely focuses on
con el and is role in Metropolis with
Superman in existence now there's almost
no action that takes place in this story
in the beginning but what this story
does is it leaves us with a cliffhanger
involving a fight between the Kingdom
Come version of Superman and Superboy
and to be quite frank I'm actually dying
to see what happens with issue number
two but the fact remains that with
convergence week two so far the stories
are sort of hit and miss like most of
the most of the events that are launched
by either DC or even Marvel not every
story is going to resonate with every
fan and not every stories who want to
resonate with anybody but the fact
remains that this is again just kind of
a last hurrah for the events for the
characters that we saw pre-new 52 it's a
way for us to more or less just kind of
say goodbye to a lot of these characters
and possibly even say hello to these
characters as some of them may be
returning post convergence but again
this is just a chance to look over these
things to channel talk about these
things and feel free to let me know down
in the comments section which characters
or which teams you'd like for me to do a
more I guess in-depth explanation on
what's convergence comes to an end
without being sent I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did let me
know and I will cut you guys